تتناول قمه العشرين مجموعه من القضايا في
لقاءاتها الدوليه منها نمو الاقتصاد
العالميه والتجاره الدوليه وتنظيم اسواق
المال العالميه فالهدف الاساسي للمجموعه
هو تقويه النظام المالي العالمي وتعزيز
اليات الرقابه عليها لمنع تكرار الازمه
العالميه الماليه التي شهدها العالم عام
2008 كما تهدف المجموعه الى عدم ترك اي
قطاع من السوق الماليه العالميه بعيدا عن
الرقابه ومحاربه التهرب الضريبي وتفادي
المنافسه عن طريق تخفيض الضرائب كما تسعى
قمه العشرين الى التركيز على تحقيق نمو
مستدامه ومستمر واقتصاد متوازن وخلق مزيد
من الوظائف للاقتصاد العالميه فمن ذو قمه
واشنطن التي عقدت عام 2008 اصبحت التجاره
العالميه احد اهم البنود على جدول اعمال
المجموعه بسبب العلاقه الوثيقه بين حريه
التجاره العالميه والحد من البطاله
ايها المناخير سياسات التنميه اسواق العمل
وقوانينها نشر التقنيه الهجره وقضيه
اللجوء ومحاربه الارهاب قضايا تدخل ايضا
في جدول اعمال قمه العشرين
[موسيقى]
يبلغ انت مجموعه ال 20 80% من اجماليه
الانتاج العالمي فيما تبلغ حصتها من حجم
التجاره العالميه 75% ويبلغ عدد سكان دول
مجموعه العشرين ثلثي سكان الكره الارضيه
طبعا مشاهدينا تضم المجموعه عددا من
المنظمات والهيئات الدوليه التي تحضر
القمه كما اسلفنا منها صندوق النقد الدولي
والبنك الدولي ومنظمه التجاره الدوليه
بالاضافه الى مجلس الاستقرار المالي
منظمه التنميه والتعاون الاقتصادي ومنظمه
العمل الدوليه والامم المتحده ويحق لرؤساء
هذه الدول المشاركه في القمه دعوه زعماء
من خارج المجموعه طبعا مجموعه ال 20 ليست
منظمه دوليه لكنها اشبه بمنتدى غير رسميه
وبالتالي المجموعه لا تتخذ قرارات ملزمه
قانونيه للدول اعضاء في المجموعه كما لا
تملك المجموعه سكرتاريه دائمه او موظفين
ثابتين ومنذ الازمه الماليه العالميه عام
2008 باتت القمه سنويه ويحضرها وزراء
الماليه ومدير البنوك المركزيه في الدول
الاعضاء في هذه المجموعه
[موسيقى]